[Música]
hablamos ahora de economía en directo
américa de france24 y para ello ya está
lista en el estudio como siempre daniela
blandón danny bienvenida ya estamos a
miércoles mitad de semana y le preguntó
entonces cómo sigue la inflación mundial
que se dispara por la guerra y también
los rezagos de la pandemia de kobe 19
recordemos que ahí empezó todo este
aumento del costo de la vida si eso no
es una cosa solamente de la guerra en
ucrania porque el aumento de los precios
en varios países ya venían récords por
cuenta de las restricciones y los
cierres por la pandemia de kobe 19 lo
que sí hizo la situación fue agravarse
desde el inicio de esta invasión rusa
como nos cuenta juan pabló como la
guerra en ucrania le sigue pasando
factura a la economía mundial y golpea
con más fuerza los precios de la canasta
familiar en marzo eeuu a registró la
tasa de inflación interanual más alta
desde 1981 con un 85 por ciento una
cifra impulsada por los altos costos de
la energía los alimentos y la vivienda
esta inflación está carcomiendo el
sueldo de los empleados estamos viendo
en estos momentos y comparamos los
salarios hace un año hasta ahora el l
estadounidense medio ha perdido 2.7 por
ciento de poder adquisitivo el índice de
precios de mexico en marzo subió hasta
el 7,45 por ciento frente a un año atrás
una tasa que no se registraba desde 2001
en colombia la inflación de los últimos
12 meses hasta marzo llegó al 8 53 por
ciento y en argentina se espera que en
marzo la inflación haya arrojado una
tasa interanual superior al 50 por
ciento la más alta de sudamérica después
de venezuela en ese país las
organizaciones sociales y políticas
salieron a las calles a protestar por el
encarecimiento de los precios formas
en los pobres mejores porque la
inflación va comiendo y pulverizando los
sueldos y los salarios de las compañeras
de los compañeros la guerra ha sido
apenas el agravante de una elevada
inflación que ya había originado la
pandemia del cubil 19 el alza de precios
del petróleo tras la guerra la
ralentización del crecimiento en china y
el atasco en las cadenas de suministro
son ahora la combinación de factores que
empeoran la situación a nivel mundial
bueno danny ante esto eeuu tomó medidas
que ya levantan polémica porque claro
pues anticipábamos ayer que la subida de
los precios en marzo interanual fue
dramática del 8,5 por ciento y el
presidente joe biden culpó a su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin de la situación
también recordó que autorizó una
liberación de las reservas estratégicas
de petróleo y anunció una medida
adicional relacionada con el etanol
los dos mayores productores de grano del
mundo china perdón ucrania y rusia no
están haciendo lo que suelen hacer así
que todo está subiendo hemos visto los
datos de inflación de hoy el 70% del
aumento de los precios en marzo vino de
la subida de precios de la gasolina de
putin
la agencia de protección ambiental
planea emitir una extensión de
emergencia que permita que la gasolina
e15 que usa más etanol de cosechas
caseras se venda este verano para
aumentar el suministro de combustible
daniela porque tan polémico todo esto
mire con respecto a la liberación de un
millón de barriles diarios de las
reservas estratégicas de petróleo hay
quienes dicen que es una medida que
debería ser tomada en casos de
emergencia de suministro y no
precisamente para bajar los precios de
manera artificial y de todas las formas
desde el millón representa apenas un 1%
del consumo mundial de petróleo entonces
no es mucho lo que haga y frente a la
autorización del uso de gasolina con
mayor contenido de biocombustibles en
verano las preocupaciones son más de
tipo ambiental porque cuando hay clima
cálido es más contaminante
también porque el bioetanol se produce
con maíz lo que podría o bien
comprometer la seguridad alimentaria o
elevar los precios nos venimos a nuestra
región porque en perú también se
anunciaron medidas no menos
controversiales claro y es que si en
eeuu la inflación es alta pues en perú
también es alta superó el 8% en eeuu y
en este país suramericano lo hizo en un
7% interanual a marzo por eso el
congreso aprobó una ley que exime del
impuesto general a las ventas a ciertos
alimentos que considera esenciales cuál
fue la polémica pues que el entorno fue
entorno en qué alimentos eran objeto de
esa exención que va a durar ocho meses
inicialmente fue polémica porque al
principio el congreso había incluido en
la lista de alimentos que el gobierno
consideró de lujo como el faisán o el
lomo fino de res la gallina de guinea o
la lasaña después de varias discusiones
al final solamente quedaron exentos
alimentos como el pollo el azúcar los
huevos los videos y el pan y es que
comer carne ya se volvió un lujo
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información económica